see how they're doing the booty drums
I know absolutely nothing about the
Brazilian butt workout no to Brazilian
waxes is it the same thing I really hope
I hear it's by the same people that did
insanity I've done insanity and it sucks
[Music]
I just hope I can sit after they're
having a hard time
[Music]
also let's give it like the back area
here like the top of my butt I feel it
in my gluteus medius
there's worried this thing's a snap and
like me in the nut squeeze that boom
boom you're gonna snap the elastic kids
if he was my trainer like one-on-one I
think you could do great things I
challenge anyone to say this is easy if
you're looking for a butt workout this
is probably a pretty good one if you're
not I don't know why you do this yeah I
don't know if I would consider do the
whole program as a dude I need to like
you said before pump wait yeah the
60-day workout is just crazy
definitely would never ever put myself
through something like that I would
actually be willing to pay for this
workout but not because I care about my
butt that much but because they did
offers cardio I don't know if I mean to
be doing this but I'm clenching my butt
after the workout so it's like my butt
is tighter let's see right there
[Music]